April 15, 2013 – two bombs tear through
the crowd welcoming runners over the finish
line at the Boston Marathon.
The carnage is total with three people killed
and dozens wounded.
Within hours the FBI have identified a pair
of suspects.
The two brothers are immigrants to America
whose parents have fled the violence of Chechnya
to give their children a better life.
So, how did it all go so wrong?
Today, through the story of the younger of
the two bombers, Dzokhar Tsarnaev, we find
out.
Early Years
Dzhokhar Anzorovich Tsarnaev was born on July
22, 1993 in Kyrgyzstan.
His parents were Anzor and Zubeidat Tsarnaev.
Anzor was a cattle farm laborer in the Caspian
region of Kalmykia.
Zubeidat was a city girl who struggled to
fit into the rural community life that marriage
gave her.
Her spirits were lifted with the birth of
her first child in October, 1986.
The couple named the boy Tamerlan, after the
great Asian conqueror.
Zubeidat was a doting mother.
She always dressed Tamerlane, who was nicknamed
Tami, in the best attire.
The boy did well in school.
His mother put pressure on her husband to
move in order to provide their son with wider
opportunities.
They returned to Anzor’s hometown of Anzor
and moved in with his parents.
About a year later, Anzor’s father was killed
in a work accident.
This left him as the family patriarch.
With the collapse of the Soviet Union, life
in the region changed dramatically.
Laborers became entrepreneurs overnight as
the western economy began flooding in.
Anzor found a job as a car repairman.
He was making a living but in order to really
get ahead he realized that he had to get to
the newly created republic of Chechnya, which
seemed like the new promised land.
The family, which now included two daughters,
moved to Chechnya in 1992.
It was there that their second son, Dzhokhar
was born.
He was named after the charismatic new President
of Chechnya, Dzhokhar Dudayev.
Within a year, things had gone horribly wrong.
The Russians invaded Chechnya and the Tsarnaev’s
found themselves in the middle of a war zone.
The family piled into a battered old Skoda
and drove back to Kyrgyzstan and the old family
home in Tokmok.
They settled back into their old lives, while
also making plans to get out of Eastern Europe.
Their goal was America.
Anzor and Zubeidat believed that their chances
of getting to America would be improved if
they obtained some educational credentials.
As a result, they both began studying law
part time.
After four years in Tokmok they sold the family
home and moved, not to America, but to Zubeidat’s
hometown of Dagestan.
However, it seemed as if this family was unable
to escape from war, and before long the streets
there were filled with gunfights and explosions.
Coming to America
The Tsarnaev family moved once again.
Anzor and Zubeidat took Dzhokhar with them
on a trip to the United States.
Tamerlan, along with the two daughters, was
left with their uncle in Kyrgyzstan.
They traveled on a 90-day tourist visa.
During that visit, Anzor applied for political
asylum, claiming that his life was in danger
due to his connections with Chechnya.
The application was submitted and the family
were allowed to stay until a decision was
reached.
The Tsarnaev’s had chosen to come to Boston,
Massachusetts.
That was where some friends had moved the
previous year, so at least they would know
somebody.
They moved in with this couple and the eight-year-old
Dzhokhar began attending second grade at a
public school along with two of the Biev children.
In April 2002, Anzor managed to find an inexpensive
apartment in Cambridge, Massachusetts and
they moved out of the Biev home and into their
own place.
Dzhokhar was left with the Biev’s for the
meantime in order not to interrupt his school
year.
Anzor and Zubeidat presented themselves as
prospective lawyers, even though their studies
had been minimal.
The were, they told people, fleeing from ethnic
strife.
They found a kindred spirit in their landlord,
Joanna Herlihy, who took them under her wing.
She took Zubeidat to an Amnesty International
event focused on human rights abuses in Chechnya
and even paid for her to enroll in a Harvard
extension course on negotiation.
Anzor picked up under the table jobs fixing
cars for ten dollars an hour.
When the school year was over, Dzhokhar came
to live with his parents in Cambridge.
His time with the Biev’s had been challenging.
The parents insisted that the only language
spoken in the home was Chechen, which he could
barely understand.
When the parents weren’t around, the children
would speak Russian.
He learned English from his association with
American kids at school, picking it up at
an amazing pace.
Dzhokhar soon became an accepted member of
the Chechen community of children in the local
area.
He was a good student who made quick advancement.
In fact, during his second year at school
he was bumped up from 3rd to 4th grade.
In mid-2003, the Tsarnaev’s asylum application
was granted.
The three children left in Kyrgyzstan were
now free to join their family in the promised
land.
With the family reunited, things were looking
pretty good for the immigrant family.
Both Anzor and Zubeidat were working and they
had permanent, affordable accommodation.
Strange New Land
Dzhokhar is remembered as a sweet, lovable
boy.
He was described as being charming.
His teachers described him as being bright,
but lacking in the ability to think creatively
for himself.
He tended to say things that got other people
to like him.
In 2003, Dzhokhar entered fifth grade.
His sisters, thirteen-year-old Ailina and
fifteen-year-old Bella were in seventh and
ninth grades, while seventeen-year-old Tamerlan
was in tenth grade.
The landlady, Joanna, tutored the children
in English, took them to movies and lent them
DVDs to watch.
Tamerlan, augmented his studies with Joanna
by reading Sherlock Holmes stories.
Being the oldest son, Tamerlan was the focus
of the family’s plans for success.
He was the golden-haired child, the one who
was destined for greatness.
He was tall, muscular and handsome.
Even Americans saw something special in him.
The Older Brother
Anzor decided that, before heading off to
college, his oldest son would become a champion
boxer.
Tamerlan proved himself to be a gifted fighter.
He had a very unconventional stance, with
his arms hanging down rather than in a defensive
stance.
After training with his father for a while,
he turned up at a local martial arts gym.
He had no mouthpiece, helmet or other protective
gear, and claimed that he didn’t need them.
When he got in the ring, he proved it.
His stated ambition was to win a spot on the
US Olympic team and to use that position as
a way of becoming a naturalized US citizen.
Tamerlan’s first victory in boxing competition
was achieved in January, 2004.
It was a golden gloves amateur bout held in
Lowell, Massachusetts.
In his post victory interview, he said . . .
I like the USA.
You have a chance to make a lot of money here
if you are willing to work.
In 2006, Tamerlan was enrolled at Bunker Hill
Community College.
For two years he focused on his studies.
Then, in 2009, he returned to boxing.
Within a year he had made it onto the national
amateur boxing circuit.
In 2010, he won the Rocky Marciano Trophy
for winning the New England Golden Gloves
competition.
But because he wasn’t a US citizen, he was
ineligible to fight for a national title.
This was a severe blow to Tamerlan and it
caused him to give up on his boxing career.
By that time, Tamerlan had also dropped out
of college.
His focus now was on becoming a music star.
He began dressing flamboyantly, with one person
describing his look as that of an Italian
gigolo.
While American teenage boys may have mocked
his look, the girls were entranced and he
had no shortage of female admirers.
In 2011, Tamerlan, the great hope of the Tsarnaev
family, was a failed boxer, a college dropout
and a father.
He was still living at home with his parents,
though his girlfriend and child did not.
For money he delivered pizza part time, and
sold marijuana on the side.
It was not exactly the career path that his
parents had in mind.
Despite their initial efforts to integrate
into American society, by 2011 the Tsarnaevs
had given up on trying.
After struggling with the language, with the
culture and even with buying things on credit,
they reverted back to what they were comfortable
with.
They decided to live as Chechens’ transplanted.
Their home had the typical Chechen look- oriental
rugs, a large plush sofa, and mirrored credenza
housing plates.
Things had not panned out as they had envisioned
– their neighbors viewed them with suspicion,
if not with outright hostility.
Their son was dealing drugs, both their daughters
had by them entered into disastrous marriages
and Anzor was spending his days fixing old
cars in the street.
Jahar
In mid-2011, Dzhokhar graduated from Rindge
college and moved to the university of Massachusetts
at Dartmouth, where he lived on campus.
A couple of months later his parents filed
for divorce.
By now all of the rest of his family had become
disillusioned with their life in America.
But not Dzhokhar.
He continued to make good grades and establish
solid, positive friendships.
He maintained his friendly, happy outlook.
At college he joined the wrestling team.
He impressed his coaches with his humility
and constant requests at what he could do
to improve.
It was a marked contrast to the American boys
on the team.
Before long, he was captain of the wrestling
team.
Just like his older brother, however, Dzhokhar
was both smoking and selling dope.
Yet, his image of the pure, sweet teenage
boy was so complete, that no-one had any inkling
of it.
Dzhokhar developed a friendship with one of
the college’s most respected professors.
Larry Aronson was the college’s official
photographer.
Aronson adopted Dzhokhar as his poster child
for kids from war torn zones who were now
attending Rindge college.
He also helped the boy to come up with a more
American friendly version of his name, Jahar.
Aronson was interested in engaging Dozkhar
in discussions about what was going on in
Chechnya, but the teenager had no desire to
talk about his old country.
Aaronson said . . .
Whenever I tried to talk to him about being
Chechen, it meant nothing to him.
Radicalization
Meanwhile Jahar’s older brother, Tamerlan,
was moving in the other direction.
In January, 2012 he flew to Dagestan.
He went to his old hometown of Makhachkala.
This was the capital of Dagestan and, over
the last ten years, it had transformed itself
into a modern city.
Tamerlan quickly fit into the social scene,
spending his days mixing with fervent young
men in their twenties and thirties who talked
about their religion, their aspirations and
the injustices in the world.
He met many of his relatives, a number of
who were involved in organized crime.
Tamerlan joined a group called Union of the
Just, which was allied to the Hizb ut-Tahrir,
one of the largest Islamic organizations in
the world.
He told members of the group that American
was a racist country that was deeply divided,
with corrupt police and a xenophobic foreign
policy.
When asked to compare America with Russia,
Tamerlan is reported to have said . . .
I refuse to choose between two kinds of fecal
matter.
Both taste like shit.
In July 2012, Tamerlan told his associates
that he urgently needed to return to the United
States because he had a problem with his documentation.
He intimated that he had no desire to go and
would come back soon.
Tamerlan returned to Cambridge to discover
that his father had himself returned to Dagestan
and had started a successful car repair business
with his brother.
A couple of weeks later, Zubeidat also returned
to Dagestan, not to reunite with her ex-husband
but to live with her family.
To Tamerlan, Dagestan was now home.
He would only stay in the US long enough to
get his passport.
Joanna Herlihy, the Tsarnaev’s landlord
had become increasingly concerned with the
radicalization of the family.
After a heated encounter with Tamerlan in
which he vented about his hatred of America,
she issued an eviction notice.
Frustration
Back at College, Jahar got a new roommate.
Andrew Dwinells ws a young American go-getter.
The engineering major was going places and
his very presence highlighted to Jahar just
how inadequate he really was.
The two never spoke and only exchanged messages
when one of them was locked out of the room.
Jahar had a small and tight-knit group of
friends, all of them being eastern European.
There was also a steady flow of customers
to his dorm room to buy pot.
Within a few months, Jahar’s social circle
had widened slightly to include a couple of
Americans.
They congregated off campus at the apartment
of a couple of members of the group.
Once, Jahar disclosed to a couple of the group
members that he knew how to make a bomb.
He also said there were parts of the Koran
that were worth fighting for with force.
Still, he was not a Muslim extremist, though
those in his group who had met his brother
considered Tamerlan to be one.
The Bombings
Patriot’s Day 2013 occurred on April 15
in 2013.
It is a public holiday in Massachusetts and
on that day in Boston the Boston marathon
is run.
Two hours after the end of the marathon, at
2:49 pm, as runners were streaming cross the
finish line, two bombs exploded near the end
of the course.
Three people were killed and 264 others were
wounded.
In the immediate aftermath of the bombing,
the police scanned the crowd in an attempt
to identify anyone who looked out of place.
Their first target was a Saudi Arabian man
who had actually been wounded in the blasts.
He was quickly cleared and then three other
Muslim men were looked at, but all dismissed.
On Thursday, April 18th, the Boston Post published
a photo on its front page along with a banner
that read . . .
Bag Men: Feds Seek These Two Pictured at Boston
Marathon.
The two men were Tamerlan and Jahar Tsarnaev.
When Larry Arronson picked up the paper, he
thought that one of the men looked amazingly
like Jahar.
Then when students at the university saw the
picture, they didn’t think that it looked
like Jahar – they were convinced that it
WAS him.
Still, his friends couldn’t believe that
he had been involved in the bombing.
He just didn’t seem capable.
Rather than going to the police of the FBI,
his friends went to Jahar’s dorm.
But the door was locked.
Unable to locate Jahar, his friends went back
to their dorm and proceeded to play Xbox.
A short time later, one of them received a
text from Jahar that read . . .
If you want you can go to my room and take
what’s there.
They returned to the room, used a spare key
to get in and began to search his side of
it.
One of them found a black backpack that contained
a large metal cylinder and a half empty jar
of Vaseline.
He turned to his friends and said,
I think he used these to make
the bomb.
Fugitives
The FBI had been focused on Jahar as early
as Wednesday morning.
They had been studying video of the aftermath
of the explosions.
It was noticed that Jahar didn’t react to
the blasts.
While everyone one else ran ducked and screamed,
he just kept right on walking.
They also noticed Tamerlan walking alongside,
nd again showing no reaction.
But they had no idea who these two men were.
The images were issued to the American public
with a warning that they were considered to
be armed and dangerous.
In the hours following the bombing, local
media blamed the pair on every crime committed
in the area, including the murder of an MIT
police officer.
They got that last accusation right.
The brothers killed officer Sean Collier in
order to steal his gun.
They then committed a carjacking at a Cambridge
gas station.
They were driving a Mercedes SUV, but they
were unaware that it was fitted with a GPS
device.
This allowed the police to track their every
movement.
They seemed to be driving around aimlessly,
which they were, having no post bombing plan
of action.
In their possession the brothers had five
homemade explosive devices, a semiautomatic
handgun, a machete and a hunting knife.
End Game
The police caught up with the Tsarnaev brother
in the early morning hours of April 19th.
They closed in on the brothers in a quiet
suburban street in the suburb of Watertown
and began randomly firing.
One of the officers was seriously wounded
by friendly fire.
The brothers were behind cover and, when ordered
to give up, Jahar threw the explosives devices
towards the cops.
They exploded harmlessly in the street.
The final shootout was between Tamerlan and
a Watertown police officer named Jedd Pugliese.
The officer scored several body hits while
Tamerlan failed to find his target.
When his ammunition ran out, he threw his
gun at Pugliese.
He then ran for it.
Pugliese and another officer ran after him.
They soon got to him and dragged him to the
ground.
But now Jahar jumped behind the wheel of the
SUV and proceeded to run down the officers.
They officers quickly jumped aside, and Jahar
unwittingly drove over top of his brother,
dragging the body thirty feet down the street.
Leaving his brother dying on the road, Jahar
sped away.
It took nearly a minute for the police to
give chase.
By then, he’d ditched the car and run off
into the suburbs.
A huge manhunt now swung into action, with
police officers scouring backyards in dozens
of suburbs and thousands of people being ordered
to evacuate their homes.
In the early afternoon of Friday, April 19,
a Watertown homeowner reported seeing blood
on the side of a boat in his yard.
A SWAT team rushed to the home.
Jahar had been hiding in the covered boat
for hours.
The officers tempted to coax Jahar to come
out with tear gas.
When that failed they fired bullets to scare
him out.
In the end an imposing officer approached
the boat and loudly demanded that Jahar come
out immediately.
A childish voice replied . . .
But it’s going to hurt!
Police officers then moved in and helped Jahar
make his way down from the boat.
He was severely wounded, with either bullet
or shrapnel injuries to the neck, ear and
thigh.
He was rushed to hospital where he was operated
on.
According to one of his nurses, he cried for
two days straight after his operation.
When the police searched the inside of the
boat that had been Jahar’s final hideout,
the found the following message written in
blood . . .
The bombings were in retribution for the U.S.
crimes in places like Iraq and Afghanistan
that the victims of the Boston bombing were
collateral damage in the same way innocent
victims have been collateral damage in U.S.
wars around the world.
Jahar’s trial began on January 5, 2015.
He was charged with four counts of murder,
along with 26 other charges.
The prosecution sought the death penalty.
Even though Massachusetts had outlawed the
death penalty in 1988, the federal charges
against Tsarnaev made him eligible for execution.
He plead not guilty to all of the charges.
The defense position was that Tamerlan had
been the mastermind of the enterprise and
that Jahar had been coerced into cooperating.
Tsarnaev showed no emotion throughout the
trial until his family members took the stand.
At that point he wept bitterly.
On April 8, 2015, Jahar was found guilty on
all 30 charges.
A month later he was sentenced to death by
lethal injection.
Dzhokhar Tsarnaev now sits in the notorious
supermax prison ADX Florence in Fremont County,
Colorado.
Meanwhile his defense team are working on
an appeal to his death sentence.